[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us troubling allegations tonight against
one of canada's highest ranking catholic
leaders quebec cardinal marqualette a
prominent priest who came close to
becoming the pope in 2013 is facing
sexual assault allegations he's been
named in one of two class action
lawsuits against the church as eric
sorenson reports in our top story
tonight these allegations mark the
latest scandal rocking the catholic
church
he's one of the most senior leaders in
the roman catholic church and one of the
pope's most trusted advisors now
cardinal mark wallach is the most
prominent figure among 88 members of the
clergy facing sexual assault allegations
in a new class-action suit against the
quebec catholic diocese the ragio canada
program unquet first reported on the
civil case involving more than 100
victims most allegedly assaulted in the
1950s and 60s but it is the allegation
against cardinal wallet that reaches the
highest echelons of the church in the
complaint a young woman said she was
doing an internship as a pastoral agent
from 2008 to 2010 when wallet then the
archbishop of quebec allegedly grabbed
her says her lawyer in 2010 during a
meeting the dallas the archbishop
ouellette went to see her and
very inappropriately hugged her and
caressed her back
very close to her buttocks in 2020 there
was a meeting for sexual misconduct
formation
and during the formation she realized
that what she
went through is was a
sexual abuse wallet is an immense figure
in quebec ordained as a priest more than
50 years ago and 20 years ago selected
to be archbishop
in 2003 he was promoted to cardinal a
respected voice in a conservative
institution we know that it is difficult
to live out you know in a sort of
atmosphere of
free sex well that was among those
considered by the college of cardinals
to replace pope benedict in 2013. the
conclave ultimately selected the
archbishop of buenos aires who became
pope francis just weeks ago the pontiff
was in quebec apologizing to indigenous
people for abuses at church-run
residential schools many cardinals were
in attendance wallet is not facing
criminal charges but a civil action a
church spokesman in quebec said we took
note of the allegations against cardinal
mark wallet we will not have any comment
about this the victim wrote to the pope
last year her lawyer says there has been
no news from any vatican investigation
erik sorensen global news toronto
there is grim news out of british
columbia overdose deaths in that
province have reached a tragic new
milestone more than ten thousand people
have lost their lives to toxic drugs
since the crisis was declared a public
health emergency in 2016. in the last
six months of this year nearly 1100
people have died an average of six
people a day
fentanyl a potent synthetic opioid has
been detected in 83 percent of all
overdose deaths this year
today i'm angry because the only thing
that's really changed over the past six
months and the past six years the young
unregulated drug supply has gotten
increasingly worse
the illicit drug market is not going to
get better organizing crime isn't
suddenly going to put out a safer supply
we have to
next year bc will become the first
province to decriminalize possession of
small amounts of illicit drugs after
receiving a three-year exemption from
the federal government
global news has learned a canadian
forces veteran who suffers from
post-traumatic stress
was offered medical assistance in dying
as one of their treatment options the
shocking and unprompted suggestion came
from the organization tasked with
helping canada's vets sparking outrage
from at least one prominent veterans
group mercedes stevenson has this global
news exclusive
when a canadian veteran picked up the
phone and called veterans affairs canada
to get treatment for his combat related
ptsd and a traumatic brain injury he
expected help getting better and getting
his life back instead he got an
unexpected and unwanted offer to help
him end it through medically assisted
death multiple sources have told global
news the veteran was shocked the agent
on the other end of the phone raised
maid as an alternative to treatment out
of the blue in a statement to global
news vac confirmed the allegation saying
the department was recently made aware
of an incident involving a veteran
client and a veterans affairs canada
employee where medical assistance in
dying was discussed inappropriately
vac deeply regrets what transpired the
incident has left the veterans community
feeling betrayed by the department i
would have to listen to voices in my own
head would tell me things like turn your
motorcycle in front of that 18 wheeler
what are you doing here you're you're no
good anymore toby miller is a former
special operations supporter seriously
injured in afghanistan he says the
demoralizing effect of being offered
death instead of treatment puts lives at
risk with veterans who already feel they
have lost their sense of purpose
reinforcing that with an offer of made
can really be a recipe for disaster for
somebody who may already be suffering
ideation or suicidal thoughts wounded
warriors canada a charity that helps
injured vets says they are deeply
concerned by the incident it's just flat
out wrong maxwell says veterans will
often only come forward once and an
offer like this could deter them get one
chance at it every conversation matters
the department says it is investigating
and has apologized noting medically
assisted death should not be discussed
by vac employees or offered as a service
however vac wouldn't say how many vets
may have received similar offers in a
statement veterans affairs minister
lawrence mccauley condemned the
interaction saying this should never
have happened and that it was completely
unacceptable the minister promised to
take action so this never happens to
another veteran both he and the
department say that administrative
action is being taken against the person
who made the offer but wouldn't say what
that meant
farah
thanks mercedes
allegations of political interference
front and center at a parliamentary
committee looking into the 2020 mass
shooting in nova scotia today's
testimony from the head of the rcmp in
that province contradicted an earlier
statement from his boss about the public
release of information about the
gunman's weapons tom vernon has the
latest
it was a mass shooting that shocked the
nation over two days in april 2020 22
people were gunned down in nova scotia
by a suspect disguised as an rcmp
officer this launched a massive
investigation and tight controls on what
information went public including what
types of firearms the suspect used the
release of that information would have a
negative impact on the ongoing
investigation appearing before
parliamentary committee chief
superintendent darren campbell who was
the head of the rcmp in nova scotia in
2020 said he had no intention of
releasing the firearms information
during a more than two hour long media
conference ten days after the massacre
once that conference ended his boss
called once the call commenced the
purpose of the call became very clear
campbell testified that commissioner
brenda lucky the head of the rcmp told
him in no uncertain terms she was
disappointed he didn't publicly release
the types of firearms because the
federal government had been assured by
her he would she immediately linked it
to ongoing
efforts to
bring forward some new legislation that
legislation turned out to be an order in
council banning 1500 assault style
weapons announced by the government just
days later both commissioner lucky and
minister blair have testified before the
same committee blair said he did not
direct the rcmp in any matter on this
file while commissioner lucky said she
did feel pressured to share more
information about the shooting the
conservatives say the conflicting
information suggests someone is lying we
don't feel that asking for the
resignation of commissioner lucky or
minister blair is off the table but we
do need to hear more testimony chief
superintendent campbell says his memory
of the meeting is clear and he believes
his testimony is critical to ensure a
proper relationship between the
government and the rcmp it's about
independence tom vernon global news
edmonton
there are signs canada's skyrocketing
cost of living is starting to ease after
a nearly 40-year high set in june the
national inflation rate has dipped
according to statistics canada inflation
slowed to 7.6 percent in july the first
monthly drop in a year and canadians
finally found some relief at the pump
drivers paid 9.2 percent less for
gasoline in july than the month before
but the cost of nearly everything else
is going up on a year-over-year basis
prices at the grocery store rose nearly
10 percent and natural gas was way up
more than 42 percent so canadians are
still feeling the squeeze and the
inflation rate is still well above the
bank of canada's 2 percent target and
gaviola is here and what does this mean
for interest rates
there are signs that inflation has
peaked and with the bank of canada
tasked with taming inflation today's
data probably means that a full
percentage point rate hike on september
7th is off the table economists tell me
we should brace instead for 50 basis
points or a hike of 75 basis points in
early september but anyway you slice it
the cost of so many things are more
expensive now than they were a year ago
and that's leaving many households
feeling financially stretched
with inflation increasing the price of
so many things we use every day many
households are looking to save and
stretch dollars during an expensive time
of year back to school shopping personal
finance expert natalie douglas will be
bartering reusing and buying second hand
my son grew out of his shoes so fast he
went from a 10 and a half and ended this
school year at a 12 and it just amazes
me how like i went through three shoes
and i bought off facebook uh marketplace
because it's just too expensive to keep
buying new according to the retail
council of canada 86 percent of
households will make back-to-school
purchases it's going to be an exciting
year i mean i'm a parent myself and i'm
looking forward to getting back to
school
shopping because it's
what we hope to be a normal year 56
percent are buying clothing nearly a
third books and music while one in five
are shopping for electronics 17
food personal finance expert sandy young
recommends using all the discounts you
can find use a cashback credit card
combine that with coupon codes from your
retailer
then add on a cashback website and this
way you can earn some rewards or
cashback while you are shopping for
big-ticket items like electronics she
suggests buying refurbished items that
come with guarantees they'll work and
lower prices you definitely want to make
sure that you are going with a reputable
seller experts agree making a list is
key before you start shopping i
definitely planned ahead i knew all the
sizes i needed to get i had a list of
actually all the items i wanted to buy
and i stuck to my list before i even
entered the shop another option hold off
on non-urgent purchases until october
selection may not be the best but
retailers will need to make room for
holiday merchandise ann gaviola global
news toronto
a high stakes vote south of the border
coming up the fate of much maligned
republican liz cheney in the hands of
wyoming voters
one of donald trump's biggest critics
within the republican party is at risk
of losing her congressional seat tonight
voters in wyoming are set to decide
whether liz cheney should be the
republican candidate in november's
midterms but as jackson proskow reports
her chances of victory seem slim in a
state that's standing with the former
president
on the frontier of american democracy
loyalty to donald trump is the only
question on the ballot in the republican
primary but we are now embracing a cult
of personality and i won't i won't be
part of that it's where congresswoman
liz chaney is on a clear path to defeat
all for refusing to cave to donald
trump's election lies and leading the
january 6th investigation he refused to
defend our nation and our constitution
she has gone crazy trump endorsed
cheney's republican rival who falsely
claims the 2020 election was stolen
she's not addressing the issues that are
important to wyoming the two candidates
share nearly identical views on every
other issue it's chaney who's behind by
double digits in the polls this cheney
has persecuted president trump democrats
were urged to temporarily switch parties
to support cheney her father the former
vice president has stepped in too there
has never been an individual who is a
greater threat to our republic than
donald trump but trump remains the most
powerful figure on the right and if
chaney loses eight of the 10 republicans
who supported his impeachment will have
been ousted or resigned that is an
indictment on the modern republican
party that you cannot take a courageous
vote the end of cheney's time in
congress is unlikely to end her
political ambitions she's raised
millions and is said to be eyeing a
potential run for the white house as an
increasingly rare breed of candidate a
pro-democracy republican
jackson proskow global news washington
u.s first lady jill biden has tested
positive for covid19 while vacationing
with president biden in south carolina
the white house says she's experiencing
mild symptoms and has been given the
antiviral drug pacslovid dr biden will
isolate in south carolina until she
receives two consecutive negative test
results her husband recently recovered
from the virus including a so-called
rebound case last month the u.s
president tested negative this morning
and returned to washington this
afternoon
war and water ahead residents face a
dire shortage in decimated ukrainian
city
in a rare admission russia says sabotage
is behind a series of explosions at an
arms depot in occupied crimea russia
says ammunition was detonated at a
military warehouse power lines rail
tracks and residential homes were also
damaged more than three thousand people
were forced to flee moscow believes
groups loyal to ukraine used small
drones to bomb the ammo depot and in the
ukrainian city of mikolayev artillery
fire can be heard in the distance as
people line up for clean drinking water
the city's main pipeline runs through
russian-occupied territory and was
destroyed in april mikalive is not under
immediate threat of capture but as
crystal commansing reports tensions
still run high over the continuous risk
of attack
water jugs are carried carded and pushed
around mikolai
across the city water is dispensed
roadside
without water for a month there was no
water at all for anything
it's possible to buy water in stores but
many of the 250 thousand residents still
living in make a life are now unemployed
and simply can't afford it instead many
people pay
with their patience
what comes from the taps can only be
used for washing clothes or showering
the main purified water line for
drinking ran through the occupied city
of kirsan and was destroyed in april
right after that line was attacked some
resorted to using puddle water
this young mother says given everything
people are currently living with lining
up for drinking water trucked in from
odessa is not the greatest challenge she
faces what is the
hardest thing she's dealing with
so my solution is the most difficult
part not being able to plan for
tomorrow unlike the city of kirsan mike
alive was never taken by russian forces
still there is no lasting peace in six
months of war there have only been 22
total days where the piece hasn't been
shattered by rockets or missile strikes
a cruise missile launch from the black
sea destroyed the mick alive military
regional administrative office back on
march 29th the horror that unfolded here
is undeniable
37 people were killed i don't want
people in other countries
feel this our war like a show
when you are tired of the war you can
just switch off the tv there is no war
but we are counting the war not in days
but you know in victims more than 120
residents have been killed the regional
governor says death and destruction has
changed everyone
people are afraid and trust has been
eroded our small crew was granted
special permits to report in make a life
but residents called police to voice
suspicion anyway concerned we might be
russian spies
people are afraid
but 15 minutes after the shelling
children are playing 20 meters away from
the courts
i saw this personally the city went into
lockdown recently so police and soldiers
could flush out any potential russian
informers and it may not be the last
time
the war is rarely far from view making
small simple pleasures stand out in
stark contrast
uncertainty itself
one of the only constants in daily life
crystal gamansen global news nicolai of
ukraine
next the plane crash survivor whose
small steps to recovery are soaring
beyond expectations
tonight for the first time an alberta
pilot is sharing her story of recovery
she was aboard a plane that crashed just
west of calgary nearly four months ago
her co-pilot was sadly killed and as
sarah often reports the 23-year-old is
now making progress toward a hopeful
return to the sky
megan gallagher never expected to find
herself here it's a lot of adjustments i
would say
an adjustment is an understatement after
the 23-year-old's high-flying life as a
pilot took a tragic turn it was
definitely really weird waking up and
being told like hey you were in a plane
crash and now you're paralyzed you know
and i had no memory of it on april 22nd
she took off just west of calgary on a
training flight in a small recently
rebuilt plane it flew for about an hour
south of the city before the plane
attempted a return when a sudden drop
from some 9 000 feet up changed
everything
her co-pilot and trainer michael wilton
a father of young twins was killed
witnesses pulled gallagher to safety
i could have ended up
dead if it weren't for them it was a
horrible horrible thing to see your
daughter
in that bed like that
but also to see that she was still alive
she was in intensive care for days
needing multiple surgeries
they said you know it's it's a complete
injury so you're probably not going to
walk again so she made it her goal and
about a month ago she took her first
steps
the strengths she has and
the resilience and determination
and she's a big planner that that's
what's getting her through all this is
she's a big planner
and megan continues to look up she
recently took her first post-crash
flight as a passenger and is hoping to
return to the pilot's chair i would love
to fly again and that's what i'm working
towards i can't see myself doing any
other job besides flying again
but you know i'll have to see as the
progress grows i'm very lucky to be here
and i feel very lucky and still
determined to prove that for her future
the sky's the limit
sarah often global news calgary
and that's global national for this
tuesday tonight's your canada is the 200
year old fishing village of fisherman's
cove in eastern passage nova scotia
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
you